if the creators of american pickers had
it their way viewers would feel as if
everything about the show is authentic
and impromptu when it comes to finding
and buying interesting items from
collectors across the country the show
frames it as if everything is
spontaneous the show's star pickers or
at least the original star pickers frank
and mike either spot something that
piques their interest on the road or
their storefront superstar danielle
calls them with a tip on a potential
picking place regardless of the method
frank and mike's picking journey across
america looks natural of course as with
all reality shows there's a little more
orchestration behind the camera than the
shows producers really want fans to know
take a touch of reality away from the
reality show and it becomes much more
entertaining as such you might not be
surprised to learn that frank and mike
aren't always the ones who do the
picking on american pickers on top of
that they might not even handle much of
the negotiating no matter the tv show
there's always a great deal of
preparation that goes behind every
episode prior to filming and reality
shows are no exception even if a
person's behaviors and reactions are
authentic and unscripted someone has
probably put a ton of effort into making
sure the episode follows a certain
guideline in the case of american
pickers that means that many locations
collections and items are decided long
before frank and mike even get there
this is not a huge secret either part of
the process is scouting out areas and
sending public calls to action to find
unique collections and interesting
locations according to a go san angelo
article about a local store featured on
the show there's a long process that
sellers go through before anyone from
american pickers even goes to the chosen
location to look around in this case the
story in question was ken's toys the
owner ken young explained that he had a
three-week lead before the production
crew showed up before that the producers
have a snoop they get somebody to go
into a site and look around the man who
came in that day he gave me his card
then i got a phone call and they said
when they would be coming young and his
family stated that mike and everyone
involved in the show were knowledgeable
and kind and they were really interested
in the stories behind the items which
young was happy to tell there's nothing
casual about the pickers process and
there's a lot of earnest effort put into
finding interesting locations and
objects to be featured on the show but
if you think that the producer's job
stops at finding collections however
you'd be wrong in addition to scouting
certain collections and items the
producers actually do a fair amount of
the negotiations not to discredit the
picking skills of frank and mike who
truly are the real deal however
producers often negotiate prices
beforehand according to living 101. that
said frank and mike have been known to
continue haggling after the seller and
producers have agreed on a price as it's
their job they always want to ensure
that they can get the best profit margin
for the sale and it's an aspect of the
business that makes the show feel more
real it makes perfect sense that the
production team would be skilled at
finding and negotiating sales the
responsibility can't be completely on
frank and mike and in reality if the two
men were the only ones doing any picking
american pickers would move at a much
slower pace than it does regardless the
entire process might be something to
consider next time you see mike or frank
randomly discover a great item in a
collection they supposedly just stumbled
upon in other words the reality of this
reality show is a bit pre-planned
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
american pickers are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you